seahorses are the world's most magical
fishes they've done more to rearrange
the body plan of a fish than any other
fish that's ever lived they've turned
their head at a right angle to their
body and turn their body from swimming
horizontally to swimming vertically they
drop their tail as a way to move forward
and turned it into a tail like a monkey
they have independently moving eyes like
a chameleon and they're the only group
of animals in the entire animal kingdom
that has true male pregnancy we don't
know how many species of seahorses there
are the estimates are somewhere between
30 and 120 they camouflage as their form
of defense so they look really different
in different habitats only by using
comparative DNA sequences can we find
out which species grouped together by
similar sequences seahorses are hard to
find as a source of food so they don't
have heavy predation in the natural
world their biggest predator is man
seahorses are highly sought after in
many different remedies from you can
find them ground up in powders you can
find them floating in bottles of wine
with the massive economic boom in China
we now have hundreds of millions of
people that have entered the middle
class and can now afford these remedies
and we're seeing at the same time
declines in seahorse populations that
are quite dramatic all around the world
everywhere we look the vast majority of
seahorses that are harvested for this
trade come as bycatch from fisheries and
where they used to be thrown back into
the water alive they're now taken out on
the docks and dried and all major
fisheries that use bottom trawling where
they're dragging Nets along the bottom
pull up tons of seahorses as they do
that and those seahorse species end up
being dried and then shipped for an
example this is a bag of a about at
least a thousand seahorses that was
confiscated as an illegal shipment
through San Francisco Airport so the
Fish and Wildlife Service came and gave
this to us and asked us if we could help
them identify what this massive
mortality here this massive pile of
seahorses what species it was it's
important to recognize that all species
of seahorses are internationally
protected under the world's Convention
on International trade in endangered
species so all countries have signed up
to say we will not harvest seahorses if
it is harmful to their natural
populations but no one's enforcing it
and so we're trying to help enforce
those regulations by identifying which
species and in some cases which
geographic areas they're being harvested
from I've douve all over the world
looking for seahorses everywhere and I
found a lot of them and I have never
ever seen
these kinds of densities so when I see
this I recognize just how intense of a
harvest over what a large area this one
little bag represents this is such a
small part of a huge international trade
there's no way we won't be pushing
seahorse species to extinction if we
keep this up
you